it's been a while since we last updated
our concept map and we've discussed
several new topics in the meantime as a
refresher here's what the map looked
like the last time we touched it the
maps getting pretty complicated at this
point and we're mostly just going to be
talking about get and not so much the
other concepts at this point so let's go
ahead and zoom in and just look at this
part of the graph okay great that's a
lot simpler one new concept that we've
talked about is the idea of a git
repository
a git repository is a collection of
files that are tracked by git as a
cohesive unit you can have lots of
different get repositories on your
computer and we'll talk later about how
repositories can interact with one
another
how do commits interact with a
repository how are they connected at
this point it's important to remember
that the current graph is not set in
stone
we can modify it to add new nodes
between already connected ones
repositories are a part of git and
commits are parts of repositories so
let's add those two connections there's
no need to keep this connection between
commit and get since it's pretty
redundant since they're already
connected through repository so let's go
ahead and get rid of that now let's
consider clone clone takes an existing
repository and creates a new one just
like it
so it should clearly be connected to
repository just one of our existing
connection types makes sense or should
we make a new one it looks like the
operates on connection would work here
pretty well now let's consider log log
shows the commits in the repository
prior to the current commit how would
you represent how it fits into the
existing map in the following quiz check
the box next to any node that you think
logs should be connected to in the text
box use the phrases for the existing
connection types or write other if you
don't think that any of the existing
ones fit remember this stuff is pretty
subjective so if you don't pick the same
thing as what we thought made sense
don't worry about it
you can keep trying until you land on
our solution or you can just give it a
shot and then continue through to see
how we did it please do try it yourself
before continuing on though